the media warned us yesterday the left
told us
that republicans were going to start to
attack kamala harris
in personal sexist horrible ways and oh
we didn't have to wait very long
the president of the united states
donald trump
already digging in to kamala
take a listen well she lied i mean she
said things that were untrue she is
a person that's told many
many stories that weren't true she's
very big into raising taxes
she wants to slash funds for our
military at a level that nobody's
can even believe she
is against fracking fracking is she's
against petroleum products i mean how do
you do that and go into pennsylvania or
ohio or oklahoma or the great state of
texas
he's against fracking fracking's a big
deal
she's in favor of socialized medicine
where you're going to lose your doctors
you're going to lose your plan she wants
to take
your health care plans away from 180
million americans 180 million americans
that are very happy with their
health insurance and she wants to take
that away
so she was my number one pick so she was
my number one pick i love her i'm
rooting for
says president trump was that sexist was
that personal no it wasn't not at all
notice all of the comments were about
her policies
and her dishonesty now the left has been
going after trump personally for
years but notice trump isn't going
personally
after kamala it's not it's not a
personal thing it's about her her
fitness for the job and her policies
why well it's because trump is a person
right that's why they go after him
personally and kamala harris isn't
she's nothing she's just a vessel for
the administrative state
she's just a vessel for the liberal
establishment she doesn't have any
deeply held beliefs she doesn't have any
convictions
she does she's just she's just there
that's what this
is about trump is going after
something bigger than just one person or
two people he's going after
a system that is a perversion of
american democracy
he's going after the whole media the
administrative government
and that's why they're all gunning for
him that's what this race is going to be
about
it's not trump pence versus biden harris
it's trump pence versus deep state
we'll get into it i'm michael knowles
this is the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back my favorite youtube comment
yesterday from ezra
when harris mentioned being a little
girl
joe immediately knew he would choose her
as his vp that's pretty do you remember
that
that was that was the big hit that
kamala made on joe
where she said when i was a little girl
i was bussed
to school because of good policies that
joe biden opposed because he's a racist
even though now i really like him and
i'll i'm so honored to be his running
mate
everyone has been changing their tune
unbiden
on kamala because it doesn't matter it's
not about
them it's about this power grab
obviously the the trump attacks were not
sexist as we were all warned to brace
yourself for the sexist
attacks the only person who's even
coming close to being blamed for a
sexist attack is tucker carlson why
because tucker carlson
brought up the inconvenient fact that
kamala harris began her political career
in sort of dodgy
not so nice ways take a listen
harris clearly wasn't picked for her
personal charm more than 30 years ago
she dated a man called willie brown he
was later the mayor of san francisco
she was 29 years old at the time brown
was 60 and still married
brown launched harris's political career
he knows her very well
last week brown publicly urged joe biden
not to pick camel harris as his running
mate
but it turns out willie brown's opinion
no longer matters in the democratic
party
jeff bezos's opinion matters so the
opinions of his
fellow bay area tech titans so this
you're not allowed to mention even
though willie brown who's a democratic
politician mentioned this
months and months ago the fact is kamala
harris dated this much older married man
and then he
launched her political career and now
nobody's allowed to talk about that
but is that sexist even that that's
that's the line i mean that's the
the sort of attack that the left is
calling what's sexist about that
you could attack a man if a man did the
same thing but maybe a little bit
stranger situation but if a man you know
had a relationship with an older married
woman and then she launched his
political career
you could bring that up that wouldn't be
called sexist it's it's just
acknowledges
something that she did but the reason
it's called sexist
and this is a broader point even beyond
this race is because the left is not
looking at these
politicians as individual statesmen with
individual visions and policies and
accomplishments
it just looks at them as vessels
for itself that's why the left divvies
up the country into
you know black hispanic asian-american
different sexual groups the reason it
does that is because
it doesn't care about singular vision
singular accomplishment
it's all just about
the establishment it's all just about
the vision it's about the administrative
state it's not individuals that are
governing us it's not politicians who
are governing us
for the left it's just this kind of
bureaucracy
that has no accountability for all
that's been the left-wing project in
america
the democratic project in america since
woodrow wilson has been going on now
for over a hundred years so it it
doesn't really care
about kamala you're going to hear these
italian sexist this racist whatever
obviously it doesn't mean anything i
think importantly here it's very good
that
tucker and trump most importantly is not
attacking harris for being tough on
crime that's one
kind of meme that we've been joking
about is kamala's a cop she put people
in prison and that's bad and that's
racist and that's
it that's such a weak line of argument
it's good to put criminals in prison
i'm glad kamala threw criminals in
prison it's basically the only thing i
like about her
it's good and conservatives should not
uh take up that left-wing line of
argument that's not going to serve us
very well
in the end the left already has no
enough problems to deal with on kamala
go after
the things that count because it raises
this question if kamala harris is this
wonderful
person it's historic it's so much better
actually
that we've got a black woman on the
ticket than this white man
she's the one who gives us hope why
didn't they nominate her
she ran for president why didn't they
pick her if she's so wonderful
and she's going to bring all this hope
to joe biden's campaign we'll get to why
in a second there is an answer but first
got to thank our friends over at first
leaf
you know you know this image this is
something maybe this has happened to you
i'm sure you've seen this in your
nightmares you're at home
you're finishing a glass of wine you say
hmm that was such a good wine i can't
wait to
reach for the bottle it's empty
we call this novenophobia you don't want
to be in that position okay you don't
you don't want to live that nightmare
that's why you need first leaf first
leaf will send you personalized boxes
of excellent bottles of wine shipped
right to your door
and here's how you can get this
incredible one without leaving your home
you just you go on you take a quiz to
assess your drinking preferences
this is something i really liked because
i sort of thought i knew what i liked to
drink and i filled that in a first leaf
took that into account but they knew
look michael what does he really know so
they'd maybe throw in one wine
or maybe two wines i said maybe try this
see how this is then you try when you
say oh my gosh this is excellent okay i
want a little bit more of that
you rate the wines and then based on
your ratings they will send you
more or less of different types of
varietals it's great you know they sent
me a box or two as freebies
when when we got first leaf on the show
and so i tried it
it's so good i i just keep paying for it
i can't i can't give it up i want you
know the highest level
package it's great they're very flexible
you can choose when
and how often to get shipments so you
know if i'm traveling or something i'll
slow it down on me i'll do every other
month
and they have 100 satisfaction guarantee
i really love these guys sign up today
to get six bottles of wine for a
ridiculously low price
29.95 plus free shipping uh go to
triforceleaf.com
knowles that's six bottles of wine for
only 29.95 at try first leaf dot com
slash knowles all right
why didn't the left nominate kamala
nominate why didn't they nominate her
new york times headline kamala harris is
the future
so mike pence may well be history
and what they mean by i mean this is
classic liberal stuff it actually is
racist and sexist when they say this
because what they always say
is that white guys are the past and all
the other races are the future and white
guys are bad and all the other races are
are good and white guys have privilege
and they're terrible and all the other
guys are good
and this is just a classical oppressor
oppressed kind of left-wing narrative
same thing on sex they'll say women are
the future you actually see
t-shirts that say women are the future
men of the past what does it mean women
of the future obviously it means nothing
because if you don't have men you're not
going to get any future of the of these
species at all but
they just have this view because
everything has to be oppressor or
oppressed and then they have this
view of history which is that the past
is very bad and the future is very good
and there's a science of history and we
know what the future is going to be
that's how the new york times can make
that claim
see how they get on the wrong side of
history with white male evangelical
straight
christian i mean mike pence checks every
terrible box for them
or you get on the right side of history
with kamala harris who they do not view
as an individual she is not an
individual to them
she is simply an amalgamation of her
racial sexual physical characteristics
that's new york time she's the future
okay
if she's the future why didn't they
nominate her another headline kamala
harris
a political fighter shaped by life in
two words
there are a lot of punch lines to that
joke but i don't want to get in trouble
so i won't
i won't say them and then the final one
new york times
excited again about a woman on the
ticket
excited again again you could have
picked her
to be the nominee and was anybody really
excited about
hillary clinton no hillary clinton and
tim kaine oh my gosh
talk about a woman on the ticket those
two
when they ran they did not run as
individuals they ran merely as a vessel
for the establishment
the liberal establishment we're getting
that again
by the way was the new york times
excited to have a woman on the ticket in
2008
sarah palin i i don't i don't remember
that
i don't remember their excitement
because again it's not even about
about a woman right it's just about an
empty
empty vessel the left is doing jumping
jacks they are doing gymnastics they are
bending over backwards and
leaping all over the place to try to
make sense of their past criticism of
these people
joe biden and kamala harris i mean i'm
talking about the radical side of the
left
i'm talking about sean king sean king a
very active black lives matter activist
he's on the left of the democratic party
here's what sean king
tweeted out during the democratic
primaries
he says i'll be frank and tell you two
democrats that i'm 99
sure i won't be supporting primarily
because of their dismal history
on criminal justice reform over the
course of their entire
careers joe biden and kamala harris
they both helped build and advance mass
incarceration
that was during the campaign couldn't be
clearer huh
until joe biden gets a nomination kamala
harris gets picked as vp
here is what he says without without a
hint
of irony without any shame he says
among current u.s senators i would rank
kamala harris
in the top three on justice reform
issues
he previously said he would 99 not vote
for her
specifically because of her dismal
history on criminal justice reform
for her entire career now he says she's
in the top three on justice reform
issues
that's it for me i am incredibly proud
to see a brilliant black woman and
hbcu grad historically black college
chosen as a vice presidential nominee
i've done political work my whole life
it's rarely things dreams are made of
kamala harris is the most progressive vp
nominee
in american history so at the very top
it's just a clear lie he's got he says
she's one of the worst on criminal
justice rome now he says
she's one of the best on criminal
justice reform but then at the end look
at that
kamala harris is the most progressive vp
nominee in american history
now how can that be the case if he's
previously criticizing
joe biden and kamala harris for being
among the least progressive in the race
what he said there at the end she's the
most progressive ep nominee in american
history
that's true he's actually it's not it's
not a lie i mean he's obviously a shill
and he'll shield for
for the democrats regardless that's
embarrassing for him but what he's
saying there is true and it's not
because of her
in another universe she could be
somewhat conservative she doesn't
believe anything
she's just an empty empty vessel but
because
of how much the left has advanced
progressively
since at least woodrow wilson for the
last hundred years
she is the most progressive nominee
because they're all on the same page
they are marching with the tides of
history
they will change their opinions and move
them to the left simply by virtue of
time remember joe biden
when joe biden ran in 2008 by today's
standards he would have been
very conservative same thing in 1990
would have been very very conservative
same thing in 1970s he had been very
very very conservative but he doesn't
believe anything
what is moving to the left is not him he
he and kamala don't they're not people
they're not individuals in the political
sense
they just go along with
the party they just go along with the
progressive
movement so what does that mean if it's
not about joe and it's not about kamala
what does it say about the system donald
trump gets the system
and we'll get into one move that's not
getting a lot of attention
but it should it should give us a lot of
a lot of uh excitement i think
about his his campaign in 2020 but first
i've got to thank our friends over at
puretalk you know how much
i love puretalk so right now who's your
wireless provider
ett verizon t-mobile what if i told you
the pure talk usa
uses the exact same network as one of
those carriers
same towers same exact coverage but
literally costs you have
so when i say i know no one believes
this when i say
it's the same network people think oh
yes it's a comparable network that's
written
it's the same one it's the same exact
one eugene from granbury texas says
good service haven't had any problems in
our travels we move around the state
pretty much since giving up at t we
really don't feel there's
any difference in the level of service
quality or accessibility we're ready to
put
this service on our ipads switching is
very easy you keep your phone they'll
send you a sim card
so you get the same great service you
currently have at half the price you can
get unlimited
talk text and two gigs of data for how
much 20 bucks a month
20 bucks a month the average person is
saving 400
per year so why is it so much cheaper
than att verizon and t-mobile no retail
stores no billion dollar a year ad
campaigns
it's just so easy uh the customer
service by the way is right here in the
u.s something i really really love
here's the deal unlimited talk unlimited
text
two gigs of data for 20 bucks a month
all you need to do is grab your mobile
phone dial
pound 250 and say keyword
michael knowles that is pound 250 or to
use the modern lingo
250 say keyword michael knowles when you
do you will save 50
off your first month go check it out
you're welcome
i'm saving you money so
it's not about these individuals it's
not about comel and biden
it's about the system notice
everything's about trump trump is this
unique guy
trump has this unique personality trump
has these kind of unique policies even
compared to republican presidents
so it's about the system what is this
the system is the bureaucracy
it is the administrative state it is the
deep state it is call it whatever you
want
that's where the laws get made people
still don't understand this even on the
right
your laws are not made in congress or in
the senate
and they're not you know signed into law
by the president
sometimes occasionally some change is
made there
but very very little and usually
especially now with divided government
the house and the senate and
different parties basically no
legislation is going to get done
your laws are made by bureaucrats who
you have not elected
who are not accountable to you who will
do whatever they want
bureaucrats who even when the president
changes right the bureaucrats are
are part of the executive agencies so
the executive should be able to change
them
the executive the president whoever gets
elected can barely make a dent
into this okay the politicians come and
go the bureaucrats remain there and the
bureaucrats pass
all of your laws we are ruled by people
who we do not vote for
that is a simple fact sometimes though
if you get the right administration in
there they can try to cut this back so
one way trump has done this is he said
for every new regulation we have to cut
two very simple thing
it's been able to reduce the size and
scope of the administrative state at
least a little bit
another thing is not replacing people
after these bureaucrats quit through
or you know as the size is reduced
through attrition
that's another good move he just
recently though one after a rule it's
the a
f affh rule you know all of this
administrative government
everything is just letters you know cdc
the fda affh they always
what is the affh rule the affh rule is
affirmatively furthering
fair housing this rule comes from 2015
from the obama biden
administration that's now this the way
republicans they used to only talk about
the obama administration
but now because joe biden is the nominee
for the democrats always the obama biden
administration so okay
it's the obama biden administration he
passes this rule in 2015.
it's it's part of the fair housing act
what this rule does
basically is set up a national system
that takes zoning rights away from local
areas
in the suburbs in particular and makes
it a national issue so bureaucrats at
the national stage
can now basically take all the power
away from these local communities
and re-zone and what this was about was
shipping in
low-income people from the inner cities
into nice suburbs now the reason for
this they always
they always make this a matter of race
right you remember joe biden said look i
think poor kids are just as smart as
white kids
that poor and black are synonymous to
the democrats right
rich and white are synonymous to the
democrats they've never they've never
been to parts of appalachia for instance
other
other areas in america it's it's not
it's a it's a racist
thing to say but that's how they look at
it and and
by conflating those two things by the
way that's how they bully you
into accepting these sorts of rules so
it wasn't it was a lawless power grab
it it it took so much power from the
local brought it up to the national
but what's worse what nobody's talking
about is a big key
to this rule from 2015 was that the
democrats knew they could count
statistically on those inner city votes
so they wanted to ship those democratic
voters up to the suburbs
to turn red or purple districts
blue this was a huge part behind it it
was
it was a ridiculous rule it was an
outrageous paragraph trump rescinded
that
okay so he's fighting back against
radical social engineering by
the obama administration directing the
bureaucrats this
power grab and he pushed back against
stealing the elections
that is a very good thing i
and he's not going to get a lot of
credit for it because it's you know it's
just one of these orders it's an
executive order right it goes to the
agencies
and this actually brings up another
point a lot of times republicans
will criticize a republican president
like trump for using executive orders
right they'll say no we need our laws
passed by congress
an executive order that's that's
ridiculous that's not the way our
framers intended for laws to be passed
hey buddy if the executive agencies are
the actual people
writing all of your laws then the only
way you can govern is by executive order
that's not trump's fault it's not even
obama's fault
that's that's just the way the
government runs and i actually want more
executive orders because at least it's
first of all it's it's an elected person
grabbing hold of the administrative
state at least a little bit
but it's also an acknowledgement that
congress does not rule us
anymore they should that's the
constitutional system the legislature
should write the laws but they don't
they really don't it's just this
administrative state so
if we're going to be ruled that way at
least want the executive to have some
control over it
and the way he does that is by signing
executive orders and if you have a
problem with that
your problem is not with trump or with
obama even your problem is with reality
and the way that the progressives have
stolen our government away from us
and shredded our constitution this is
rationalized
rule of the elites and you see it even
in language you see it even in the way
that they make the minority groups that
they invent refer to themselves
including most recently
la tinx that's a new you can't say
hispanic or latino it's latinx we'll get
into
how few latinx actually know what that
word is
in one second first though gotta thank
our friends over at netsuite by oracle
the world's number one
cloud business system finance hr
inventory e-commerce
everything you need all in one place so
you save time money and headaches
whether you're doing a million or
hundreds of millions in sales netsuite
gives you
visibility and control so you can manage
every penny with precision
join over twenty thousand companies who
trust netsuite to go faster with
confidence
netsuite surveyed hundreds of business
leaders they assembled a playbook
the top strategies they're using as
america reopens for business
now is the time to read it this is a
free guide
seven actions businesses need to take
now i know a lot of businesses are
struggling right now
this is the time read it it is for free
you can schedule your free product tour
at netsuite.com
slash knowles canon wles that is your
free guide
you can schedule your free product tour
right now at
slash netsuite.com k n w l e s
netsuite.com
slash knowles le tinx
le tinx that's the word that's the word
that the white liberals are telling us
we have to use
so maybe you've seen this somewhere
especially if you've been in college or
high school recently
i don't know i guess they put the x
because they don't like that latino ends
in an o
because that's masculine and and male is
bad and that's the past and women of the
future
so now it's x it's gender neutral they
could just use the term hispanic but now
they're trying to differentiate between
the term hispanic and latino both of
which by the way are just completely
ridiculous jargon
invented by the left about 50 years ago
vented specifically or
propagated specifically by the ford
foundation other radical
left-wing influence groups so in any
case
they took they took a survey this came
out from the pew research center
on tuesday they found out that only one
in
four adults in the united states who
identify as hispanic or latino
have ever even heard the term le tinx
three quarters of hispanics have no idea
what this ridiculous term lettings is
and only three percent of hispanics
actually
use that term to describe themselves
97 do not and yet what you are going to
be told
now especially if you're in a university
or
k through 12 for that matter or in
corporate america or just about anywhere
you're going to be told
that if you don't use this word lettings
you're a racist
you're outdated you're in the past if
you don't use a word
that 97 of the people that word is
supposed to describe
don't use if you don't use a word that
75
of people who are supposed to be that
word
don't even know about don't even know
what it is
then you're a racist that's what they're
going gonna say
this is not grassroots
we we sometimes think of the progressive
movement as being grassroots you know it
springs up from the people crying out
for a more progress it's not
it's completely contrived and it's
contrived by
mostly white liberals and it's been
enforced
mostly by the white liberal
establishment and
it just marches onward and we've all got
to catch up
because it's got so much power
the one consolation though you know we
talk about the the conservative
consolation on this show
a lot it's that reality reasserts itself
sometimes sporadically eventually
these liberal elite schemes are not
popular with the actual people you see
it in the word lettings but you see it
in the
in the more tangible policies all around
us things like defunding the police
the left is now no no longer even saying
that we need to
allow these peaceful protesters who are
burning down the country
that we need to allow them to kind of
run its course
you have some of the radicals of the blm
organizers coming out
and and defending the looting as justice
they're defending this theft and this
vandalism as a positive good
take a listen i don't care
if somebody decides to loot a gucci or a
macy's
or a nike because that makes sure that
that person eats
that makes sure that that person has
clothes that makes sure that that person
can make some kind of money because this
city obviously doesn't care about them
not only that that's reparations that is
reparations
anything they want to take take it
because these businesses have insurance
they're going to get their money back my
people aren't getting anything
that's it they're not getting anything
that don't how oppressed does that woman
look she's so oppressed it's so awful
that she's got to be in
modern america well-fed sort of well
protected by the cops she wants to
defund on television
running roughshod over the entire
country stealing stuff defending theft
without any consequences was she's
oppressed you know
she's getting she's getting what's hers
it's not even just at this personal
level it's not even these peaceful
protesters stealing
gucci and nike sneakers you know for
justice or something
this is happening in a systematized way
it's happening all the way at the
political level aoc just tweeted out the
other day
said billionaires need the working class
the working class does not need
billionaires which is a very funny
statement to make
while you are clamoring endlessly
to take the billionaire's wealth wait we
are told
aoc is simultaneously telling us that
people will die
the world will fall into chaos if we
don't get the billionaire's wealth
so that's why we need to expropriate it
and steal it theft at the bottom level
of looting a store theft at the top
level of taking taking people's
wealth from the from the government
through the government rather
we're told that but we're also told we
don't need those billionaires it sounds
like you do
if you're saying we're all going to die
if we don't steal all their money it
sounds like we need them huh
the whole argument is we do need them so
give us your money
that doesn't that doesn't matter no one
thing i've asked myself
is i've never understood this why on
earth would these oligarchs
these bureaucrat oligarchs why would
they
want to encourage this kind of system
this kind of
chaos in the streets this lawlessness
this injustice this theft don't you
think they'd want to just keep all their
money right wouldn't it just be all the
billionaires
no because the more
that law breaks down the more more law
order breaks down
the more property rights break down the
ability to own your own wealth
the more local attachments break down
the more attachment to family breaks
down the more
local government breaks down the more
all of these things break down
the more power the progressive
administrative state gets
never let a crisis go to waste
you need to foment this kind of chaos
it's why the left does it every election
year
to grab a little bit more power more and
more and more and more power
to the point where you've got the
national government telling people
how they can zone their neighborhoods
where you've got the federal government
coming in and telling people exactly how
much money they're allowed to have
and how much they're not and it's going
to be arbitrary it's going to change all
the time
you've got the administrative government
which issues
all sorts of rulings on what words to
use what language to use
if you don't use it it'll be a civil
rights offence you'll get hauled before
an administrative tribunal
telling 97 of people who who don't don't
want to use this term that they have to
use this term to describe
themselves even telling
they flaunt their power in such
outrageous ways
and this comes right down to this this
very
contemporary issue of the masks i've
been telling you for months
that the masks are not about protecting
public health
there is very little evidence that the
masks work at all there is a lot of
evidence that the masks don't work at
all
there's a disclaimer on every mask that
you buy right now that says this mask
does not prevent the spread of any
viruses
and that's a disclaimer that was put
there by the same administrators
who tell you you have to wear the masks
the head of the wisconsin department of
natural resources
just told his employees
wear your mask even if you are home
to participate in a virtual meeting that
involves being seen
such as unzoom or another video
conferencing platform
by people who are not on our staff this
was preston cole head of the wisconsin
department of natural resources set the
safety example which shows you as a dnr
public service employee
about the safety and health of others
shows a couple of things
the masks are a symbol obviously if
you're at home alone you don't need to
wear the mask
but it's not about preventing the spread
of a virus it's about
a political symbol the left cannot allow
for prudence
right that's what a basic what do i
think about the masks if you're in a
really high risk category and you've got
a really good mask and you're gonna be
around a lot of people maybe you should
wear it
probably it won't do anything but
couldn't hurt right and then if you're
healthy and you're
out at home and you're on a conference
call or you're young whatever
you really don't need to wear the mask
that's prudence
that's using judgment that's me the
individual
assessing the situation figuring out
what's right
taking the inherited wisdom of my
ancestors looking around just being
practical using common sense
there's no common sense in the
administrative state
it's all about highly rationalized rule
there's a rule for everything
one day we're told you cannot wear the
masks we're all gonna die if we wear the
masks
the very next day we're told you have to
wear the masks we're gonna die if you
don't wear the masks
and there's no they don't blink they
just look straight at you
they tell you that with a completely
straight face because they're the
experts and you damn well better do
what they say to do that that is the
more important thing
regard forget about the masks the most
important thing is you listen to them
these unaccountable bureaucrats who have
usurped our government
we've got to get into the mailbag we
will do that one second first though
gotta thank you thanks for going over to
our youtube channel
subscribing liking sharing it really
appreciate that
also all access members you know that's
the highest tier of membership they get
to join all access live there's a lot of
other great stuff
you get not one but two leftist years
tumblers with your membership
as well as early exclusive new daily
wire products which you saw last week
with our limited edition baseball bat
that not even i got to get it was only
available to all access sold out within
48 hours
go to dailywire.com knowles right now
get 20 off all access
with coupon code access dailywire.com
coupon code access
get 20 off your membership we'll be
right back with the mailbag
all right let's get into the mailbag
first question from may dear michael i
am nearly 30
and have strong catholic beliefs i have
always dated
cradle catholics but they were never
really believers as i am yeah sometimes
you know they're
a little more just cultural about it
they don't really believe it
i believe in waiting until marriage for
sex which gets increasingly difficult
when trying to date the older i get
i met a great guy and i really thought
we were perfect for each other
and we had plans to get married and for
the future against what i
knew was right i slept with him and were
no longer together whoever i meet next i
would still want to wait until we are
married but i'm afraid i messed up and
another good man may reject me because
of my transgressions
i feel lost and hopeless that having a
family may never happen for me
do you have any theological perspective
or advice on how i handle any of this
thank you yeah go to confession confess
your sins pray a rosary and you'll be
fine
i don't i don't mean to be flippant
about it people make mistakes
especially that everyone makes that
mistake these days virtually everyone i
mean
you know we're in a culture that's
saturated by sex where we're told that
having sex before marriage is
essential to do and you're a weirdo if
you don't do it and
you know you you just have to there's a
lot of pressure i mean there are
there are actually circumstances here
that that i think do mitigate
this sin a little bit but sure you did
it
it's wrong it is wrong even though
everyone does it even though a lot of
people do it it's wrong and
you feel sorry about it move on you know
your redeemer lives your savior lives
there there is a way for your sins to be
forgiven your sins are forgiven
you'll be fine we live in a very broken
culture too so if you're worried that
everybody else is so perfect and you're
not perfect
so you're never gonna find a husband
come on give me a break
you'll be all right these things happen
i'm sure i'm sure you'll meet a very
nice man by the way
i'm nearly 30 these days i'm you know
i'm 32.
that's like young to get married
according to the culture i know that
it's not
in traditional standards i wish i had
gotten married much younger i'm sure you
do too
but you you've also got to recognize
these kind of cultural realities
and give yourself a little bit of grace
a little bit of a little bit of uh
breathing room here you know now maybe
if this last guy you dated was a jerk
maybe even wasn't a jerk sounds like he
was kind of a jerk but let you know
regardless find a better guy the next
time
it's okay breathe your savior lives
god forgives your sins you can forgive
yourself from nick
hey michael i'm very confused and would
appreciate it if
you could clear my head joe biden has
announced kamala harris as his running
mate
joe promised he would pick a woman and i
have have to assume he made his choice
the same way he picks every girl
by grabbing their shoulders from behind
and taking a long deep sniff
judging them based on scent this is
where i get confused though
by all accounts commonly fragrance is
less than alluring
reportedly being somewhat of a blend
between the marijuana she smoked
while locking up thousands of black
teenagers mixed in with leftover traces
of willy brown's cologne here
let's go get me in trouble so with his
normal discerning methods off the table
what do you think are biden's real
reasons for picking her
i think we got to stop reading comments
from nick is what we got it nick is
going to get my show
canceled but very good observations nick
i got to tell you
you are an astute observer even if you
are going to get me fired from
alona dear mr coffee i've been an
atheist most of my life but
lately i find myself listening to mostly
christian conservative podcasts and
media
so as a 25 year old i've dated around a
little bit not too much and now i really
just want to get married and have a
family
my question is how do you know when you
found the right person
i'm torn between the notion that the
effort you put in matters
put in more than the person you choose
and fear of choosing the wrong person
and subjecting myself
and my children to a bad marriage thanks
i'm a huge and long
time fan yeah i think now i mean i think
what you've said sums up what a lot of
people think which is
this stupid hookup culture is really
dumb and maybe you know maybe i
dated around a bit but actually the
thing i want to do is the thing that is
being discouraged
by the culture by the way to serve
political ends
the re there is a reason that the the
left
and the administrative government is
pushing
uh progressive bizarre radical sex
policies on you
that's not an accident and it's not
about your freedom
the reason they do it is to break down
the family which is the bedrock
institution
stopping them from grabbing all of their
power so they do want to do i mean you
see
even during kova they always say don't
don't have sex with people have sex with
yourself you're your safest
sex partner remain alone be empowered
live in a pod go just work all the time
serve the system
life of julia during the obama campaign
they just imagine this woman cradle to
grave she never has any meaningful
relationship with anybody
other than the government they they said
she chose to have a child
that's one stage in this progressive
utopian dream life
she doesn't fall in love and get married
and have a father for her child
she chooses to have a child and then the
big government is there to take care of
you
so on to your specific question that's
the preface
your specific question is should i just
marry the next guy i see or should i
really spend a lot of time
thinking about who the right person is i
i think you're right that in this
culture
people are too slow to act to get
married
this happened to me too this happens to
a lot of friends i know they'll just
date for a long time
because we're so nervous about picking
the wrong person that that said though
i think my life would be worse if i
married someone other than sweet little
elisa
i could do it and it would be it would
be fine maybe maybe it wouldn't be so
fine
but i think you know generally mary said
when you can make it work
because marriage marriages marriage is
an institution
it's about the other person obviously
but you together you and this other
person
are forming a new thing which is an
institution so
you can make that work but i got to tell
you i do think my life would be
significantly worse if i had married
someone other than sweet little alisa
the person does matter too
how do you know when you found the right
person well
whenever people ask me this sort of
question i say are you attracted to that
person
are you excited by that person does that
person make you want to go spend time
with them
do you like something about them that's
got to be there
i mean that's very important but then
you will grow together
you'll grow together or you'll grow
apart so that shared experience is very
important too i asked
my grandfather this he and my
grandmother have been married now i
don't 65 years
something something like that maybe more
and
i said what what are the keys to a good
marriage he said well
shared experience they've known each
other since high school
and my grandmother was pregnant i think
for 54 months
lots of you patience obviously you need
lots of patience for the other person
and frequent absence my grandfather was
in the navy so you know he would deploy
a fair bit
i don't know you don't need to go away
for nine months at a time but you do
need to be able to at least have your
sort of separate
spaces every now and again but but those
those things make a lot of sense to me
and that shared experience is what
you're getting at
if you like this guy if you
love this guy if you have a good time
together if you have the same view of
the world
if you see the world the same way and
you recognize objective reality
then you'll grow a lot more together if
you know once you're married
regardless then you have to spend all
this time
thinking and making sure it's rationally
perfect to do it right
right you know before you pull the
trigger from alex
michael i'd like some advice on tithing
would you consider donating to political
activist campaigns the best example
being pro-life organizations
as being an acceptable inclusion in the
ten percent
i don't mean exclusively donating to
political campaigns but simply
uh putting part of the 10 you know tithe
toward politics
i ask this because i don't make a lot of
money and i think donating beyond 10
of my earning would be bad financial
stewardship
sure i think that's fine i don't think
that you're obligated
anymore as a christian to tithe exactly
ten percent
you should give alms but st paul i think
is clear in first and second corinthians
give what you have give what you can
give but you are not bound by precise 10
anymore i know some people may disagree
with me on that but
i say all of that to to say
it is good to give to pro-life
organizations that's a good thing
and if you do that i think that would be
very good and i i don't i don't think
you need to give 11 or 12
to make that happen from melody
dear mr knowles my friend's daughter
floored me with a statement she made
recently that the pyramids were not
built by slaves
i immediately thought to myself where on
earth has she heard this nonsense
i then began looking up articles on the
subject one article in particular by
jonathan shaw who built the pyramids
shaw states the pyramids were not built
by slaves but by privileged laborers
he goes on to say that the notion of a
vast slave class in egypt originated
in the judeo-christian tradition and has
been popularized by hollywood films like
cecil b demille's ten commandments
is this yet another attempt by liberals
to erase history and gaslight americans
into thinking we invented slavery
i think what it draws on is this highly
reductive
view of slavery that's overly simplistic
slavery has meant different things at
different times
even in america slavery in the 17th
century first of all was not
racialized to the degree that it became
in the 19th century
so so in this kind of ironic quirk of
history the first
legally recognized owner of an
officially declared
arbitrary slave for life you know the
precursor to what you would call
american slavery
was a black guy he was the first
officially declared slave owner anthony
johnson
and he owned another black guy john
casor obviously
this developed over time and by the 19th
century you have this highly particular
racialized kind of slavery
but even in america was different and so
different kinds of labor existed you see
slavery in the bible you see slavery
going all the way back a lot of
historians now say that
slaves did not build the pyramids but
some some system of labor did
and regardless of the specifics of that
we know slavery long predates
the west you're actually western
explorers
and merchants bought slaves from slave
markets in africa
there already was slavery in africa for
a long time there is still slavery today
and by the way liberals are often
participating in it because a lot of
that slavery
is in east asia so as with everything i
would i would suggest
the real history is just complicated
life today is complicated so obviously
history is too
from derek michael would you smoke a
black and mild gas station cigar
why cigar over pipe i guess i
why it depends how desperate i was you
know i usually like it maybe a little
notch above that but
white cigar over pipe cigars are just
much better
the the tobacco is usually much better
quality it's long filler so it burns
better it's more complex there's there's
a more intricate creation process
because you get the blending then you
get the rolling
they're easy you just clip it light it
pipes take a lot of work a lot of effort
i like a pipe every now and again but
i've once heard tobacco compared
to different parts of our soul so you've
got like the
the appetite the emotional part that
would be cigarettes
right cigarettes you just it's you're
feeding it addiction cigars
are the spirited part you know it's it's
you think of
big guys with big chests puffing outward
you know
most of the smoke goes out eventually
and then you have the pipe which is the
sort of philosophic
logical part i'm more for the spirit
i think we need a lot more spirit here i
like the logic too but i want some
spirit all right that's our show
i'm gonna go have a cigar clear up my
nose but
that'll be us for the week we've got
more cool stuff coming out otherwise
i'll see you on monday i'm michael
knowles this is the michael knowles show
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies
executive producer jeremy boary
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
technical producer austin stevens
assistant director
pavel wadowski editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer robin
fenderson
hair and makeup nika geneva production
assistant
ryan love the michael knowles show is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 20. hey
everybody it's andrew clavin host of the
andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the american republic is
collapsing the
end of days is approaching and the moon
has turned to blood but on the andrew
clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way
through the apocalypse with me andrew
[Music]
clayton